billionaire businessman elon musk has
delivered an eagerly awaited update on a
spacecraft he hopes will eventually take
people to other planets saying he's
confident it will test launch this year
the starship rocket is bigger than those
that took astronauts to the moon it's
central to musk's plans to colonize mars
his company spacex is still waiting for
u.s government approval for the starship
to carry out its first test flight
it's been a difficult week for spacex
after it lost 40 freshly launched
satellites to a solar storm
let's get more on this now from keith
cowing in washington d.c he's editor of
the website spaceref.com good to have
you with us again so a massive rocket in
the making what's the latest on elon
musk's ambitions
well he gave quite a show tonight with a
rather prominent uh backdrop by 400 foot
tall rocket
uh which if it were to fly tomorrow
would be the largest thing to ever fly
the last largest rocket ever built pick
your support
and uh you know a lot of people there
were quite excited but you know folks
always want more numbers and the media
always wants more details than he's
willing to give so
half and half
but it's not all smooth sailing there at
spacex i understand now many of its
satellites have been destroyed in orbit
how did that happen
well
it's not uncommon for the sun to
influence earth's atmosphere and weather
it's usually predictable but when
something happens like a solar flare you
have maybe a day or so notice sometimes
hours and in this case they launched the
satellites the sun through a flare at
the earth's atmosphere it's
swelled up and they asked the you know
the impact was that the satellites came
in before they had a chance to go higher
up so it was an unfortunate coincidence
predictable to some extent but then
again it's we call it space weather and
you know what they say about the weather
how dependent has nasa become on spacex
for achieving its goals
well a few years ago nasa went from you
know flying the space shuttle which was
very expensive to looking at ways to use
the private sector to launch cargo to
the space station and cruise and they
eventually picked several companies
spacex was one that got both the crew
and the cargo and in the ensuing years
they've saved the agency not only a lot
of money but they've learned how to do
things that nasa itself couldn't do and
they've applied that expertise to the
big rocket they were talking about so
in addition the rocket that we were
talking about the big starship the top
part the starship itself is actually
what they're going to use uh for nasa's
first landing of humans on the moon so
there's a lot of overlap here between
what spacex is doing what nasa's doing
and what the two of them are doing
together so they depend on each other
keith thank you so much that was keith
cowing there the editor of spaceref.com
you